Chúng ta đã khai mà chỉ làm quốc phòng thử nhìn, defense development, hang in không trọng làm tại thủ đồ bình dưỡng.
Đấy rau năm 2018, tiếp sự kiện được tủ chất.
Dí ra như dị kiến em tám in ăn thành lập đảng lâu động chử tiền.
Chị làm quý tụ nhiều quán chức cấp cao nhá qua bởi kỹ sư trong lệng công nghiệp của phòng.
Phà biểu tại lễ khai mà, nhá lãnh đạo kiêm trình hương khẳng đệng.
Hẹn đại hóa quân độ là ước tiên hàng đầu, với nước khảm nhân giữ phai trọng chụ cộn chống chế lược phòng thủ của gia.
Ông trở biết, chưa tiên là đạt nhiều tiên bộ trong phát triển cầy thông vô khi ứng dụng trị tuyệt nhân tạo và công nghệ tiên tiến.
Nha lãnh đạo kiêm trình hương đồng thời lấy nảm viện liên mình nghĩ hàng,
đẩy mạnh hợp tá hành nhân và tập trận quý mọi lớn, khói đây là mũi đây soạn nghiêm trọng đối với anh điên khu vực.
Ông cảnh báo, bình dẫn sẽ áp sống của biển pháp hôn sử và công nghệ tương ứng, nhằm suy chi cân bằng chiến lược và bỏ vệ trụ quyền của gia.